government's unveiled its second major
welfare support plan in a week this time
aimed at self-employed workers affected
by covert 19 joining us from Westminster
as the business secretary Alok Sharma
hello to you mr. sharma thank you for
joining us I know that you guys are
really busy but I'm sure that you
appreciate how important it is that you
talk to viewers directly at these
challenging times and allow me to ask
some of the questions on their behalf
it's a lot of money but no payments
until early June five weeks before they
can get income support what should
people do well okay this is an
unprecedented response that we've had I
think by any international comparison
what we're offering it is really quite
substantial
you're right this is a complicated
system we haven't done this before
we want to set this up as quickly as
possible and obviously we have set the
start of June as as a date for that in
terms of the support that people can get
currently of course if you have a
mortgage you can get a three month on
which holiday for those people who are
under self-assessment as a self-employed
will be normally they would be due
payments to be made at the end of July
to the the revenue we've said that can
be extended until 2021
we've also said that you know those
people who have 80 registered can defer
those v80 payments for a a quarter and
of course as you said there is support
additional support through the welfare
system we've increased the amount of
money for the standard allowance in
universal credit by over a thousand
pounds and we've also ensured that the
minimum income floor which applied to
self-employment earnings has also been
removed there is half a billion pounds
that has gone in to local authorities in
terms of a hardship fund so we are doing
everything we can to small people but I
completely understand that people will
be worried and they want us to get this
money to them as quickly as possible
and I can tell you we are literally
working night and day to make sure that
system is up and running I'm sure you
are and I'm sure people are appreciative
of that but why didn't you do like other
countries have done including Ireland
and say there you go there's a flat MI
of three hundred pounds this is going to
tide you over until you can get your
money well you talked about the the
welfare system in terms of universe
credit that I was employment minister
for 18 months and responsible for
universal credit and and we've ensured
that people can get up to a hundred
percent of as an advance of their first
payment upfront on the first day if
that's what they needed so there is
money available in the system as I said
there is that like tomorrow
no that is like tomorrow it can happen
within a matter of days and in certain
cases where people particularly need
that cash that can happen tomorrow I
mean that is how the advances system
works in universal credit so we want to
ensure that people get the support and I
completely understand there are lots of
people across our country who are
worried about their livelihoods they're
worried about their their safety and
that is why if you look at the sum total
of the package that the government has
put forward it is not only unprecedented
but it is about making sure that we
support our businesses we support people
in terms of their jobs and we support
livelihoods and the Prime Minister has
always been very clear we will do
whatever it takes to support people and
that is what we are doing with the
packages that we've outlined okay
several other things to touch I'm not
least that you said once this is all
over this is what really I said
yesterday the self-employed will be
paying more tax in the form of national
insurance that's a fundamental change is
that going to be a permanent change well
I think you need to look very carefully
at what the Chancellor said he was
making a factual observation about the
fact that the support that we're
providing for the self-employed through
this package is very similar to the
support that we're providing for those
people who are in employment and it is
the case that there is currently a
differential in the way that there is
tax treatment for people who are
employed and self-employed and he was he
was making observation and he clarified
that in the Q&A that took place
yesterday but right now what he the
prime minister I and everyone in
government is actually focused on is
getting support to people as quickly as
possible on Monday we launched the
business interruption loan scheme we've
got over 40 providers who are who are
making sure that business is supported
and I go back to this point kaa said yes
we're making these announcements but I
am also very acutely aware of the fact
that we need to get support to people as
quickly as we can and
doing everything we can to make sure
that okay I think that was a yes or no
question if if I'm a minister is it a
permanent change or not well I didn't
think there has been a change it was an
observation that the Chancellor was
making about the tax system as I said
the focus right now and I know that's
something that the British public wants
as well for that focus to be on getting
support to people whether they're
employed or self-employed right now and
that's what we're making sure have yeah
but they are gonna have to pay more tax
when all this is over in the form of
national insurance it's the fundamental
change is it a permanent change or is it
something that you will look at and look
at again in the fullness of time well I
think if you if you look carefully at
the words the chance their permanent
changed yes or no well okay absolutely
I'm speaking on behalf the Chancellor
tax policy is a matter for the
Chancellor and ultimately the Prime
Minister and the Chancellor was very
clear he wasn't sort of setting out a
change in policy at this stage what he
was saying very clearly was making an
observation of fact and what he was also
very clear about that the package of
measures yesterday was about supporting
people now he also set out in a
statement that the sum total of the
package that we've put forward to
support businesses and individuals and
it is a substantial package it is
unprecedented and we are in
unprecedented times and we have to rise
that challenge and that's what I believe
we've done is the government how long
can we afford this for our economics
editor Eddie Conway estimating it'll
cost around nine billion just for three
months looking at other figures saying
it would continue on as we are with all
the bailouts is with businesses etc it's
going to cost in excess of a hundred and
fifty billion pounds perhaps even more
how long can we afford it for well we
have said we will do whatever it takes
to support British people to support our
businesses and that is what we're doing
you know obviously there will be an
impact in the short term on borrowing
but the focus right now has to be about
supporting individuals that your viewers
who are phoning in to ask quite rightly
those there's very searching questions
of government ministers but the bottom
line here is we get support to people as
quickly as possible and that's what the
sum total
support that we have announced is all
about by any measure we are crashing the
economy at the moment do we have any
choice what well I don't think we are
crashing the economy what I would say to
you is that there this is a global issue
which is affecting countries across the
world
we are providing the support has indeed
others are for their businesses for
their citizens and that is right and
proper and I hope that the the downturn
if I can put it like that and the the
the impact in the economy is going to be
short-term but what people in
constituencies like mine are most
interested in right now is when they can
get that support and what support is
available for them and that's what the
government is setting out right now so
we're not crashing the economy let's
hope that that clip weathers well we'll
have to wait and see talk to me about EU
ventilator scheme apparently EU
countries I'm told are buying in bulk to
cut the costs and Britain stayed out of
it because we've left number ten
claiming it's not ideological but we
didn't get the email on time what well
if I can just sort of unpack that a
little bit in terms of ventilators so
there are 8,000 ventilators currently on
the frontline in the NHS we are
procuring another 8,000 through our
normal supply chain and thousand those
will be coming online to the frontline
within a matter of weeks we also
launched the ventilation challenge and I
can tell you Kay that over 3,000
businesses across our country have
responded to this and you've seen as
well the the huge response that we've
had to people who want to volunteer and
support the NHS I mean you know this is
a [ __ ] this morning the Europeans are
partial okay let me take your question
I'm not here to to dodge your questions
I just wanted to set out what we're
doing in terms of getting more
ventilators online as you said the
scheme that the the EU was was talking
about there was a miscommunication and
in fact the tendering process had
already started and what we've also been
very clear about is if there are any
future such schemes of course we will
look to participate in them but as the
EU itself has been very clear actually
every single country individually is
doing its bit to procure more
ventilators to make sure more
ventilators are built and that is what
the UK is doing as well but a ventilator
challenge ok the housing market falling
off a cliff according to the front page
of The Times this morning not lending
money don't sell your house you can
still put it on the market but you can't
move at the moment is that just one of
those casualties that we're just going
to have to come back to when we've got
the bandwidth well we've had some
guidance that the housing section has
put out this morning which is you know
perfectly sensible guidance on how
people should conduct themselves in this
market clearly there are people who have
got a mortgage who have exchanged we
have talked to the the multi lenders and
we have agreed that they would look to
extend those mortgages to a point at
which completion can take place we're
also talking to the conveyancing sector
to make sure that practically completion
dates can be moved forward but of course
people will understand that at this time
they should where it is at all possible
move their their dates for completion
but also move their their dates for
moving into new homes clearly where
someone is moving into an empty home or
there are particularly exceptional
circumstances or we say to people is
please observe the public health England
guidance when it comes to how you
interact with with other individuals but
you know okay
your listeners your viewers who will be
watching this will absolutely agree with
the guidance that we put out there which
is that at this time people should be
looking to delay any moves this is about
safety for them and safety for others in
our communities okay quick thought
before I let you go no we're out of time
I was a bit teary clapping for our
carers last night what did what about
you yeah absolutely I mean my family and
I we were in our driveway and I mean it
was really quite emotional because you
you heard this ripple of clapping and
applause down the street and this was
echoed in towns and cities across our
country the NHS is a fabulous
institution and we are providing all the
support we can to the NHS because at the
end of the day it is them and it's
delicious workers who are helping us get
through this very difficult time
no no I know as a key worker you have to
come out and leave the family at home
and we really do appreciate you taking
the time I hope you and your family keep
well thank you thank you very much